hey crazies the James Webb Space
Telescope also known as jwst or web for
short has been giving us incredible
images for a little over a year now
we've seen some of the first galaxies to
ever form and we've gotten to look at
our local space in an entirely new light
pun intended but between ballooning
budgets a decade and a half of launch
delays and a controversy over the name
getting this thing into space was kind
of a nightmare
thank you you may have heard that jwst
was meant as a replacement for Hubble
but that's only partially true to the
timeline Hubble was launched in 1990 and
the Space Telescope Science Institute or
stci was already discussing the next
mission seven months earlier in
September of 1989. at the time it was
called the Next Generation Space
Telescope or ngst we'll get to the whole
naming drama a little later it was a
whole thing anyway this 1989 meeting was
basically just a brainstorming session
which means they lived by rule number
four go big or go home they imagined a
space telescope that had a 10 meter wide
primary mirror with sensors for all
visible infrared and UltraViolet
wavelengths this was way too ambitious
and those plans did not last long by
1993 the 10 meter mirror had already
been downgraded to an 8 meter one which
is actually a meter and a half larger
than it ended up being and by 1997 NASA
had also decided to scale back the
sensor range that's when it became clear
this next Generation telescope would not
be a Hubble replacement Hubble could see
slightly into the infrared but its main
focus was visible in ultraviolet light
the plan for this new telescope was to
focus entirely on infrared plus it was
set to launch well before we retired
Hubble by 1999 NASA had some thorough
designs and an estimated timeline launch
would happen in 2007 with a total cost
of 1 billion dollars uh yeah neither of
those happened the cost quickly
ballooned a year later the budget had
almost doubled by 2005 the cost had more
than tripled by 2008 a year after the
original launch estimate it had
quintupled by 2011 it had risen to 8
billion dollars and it was nowhere near
launching this is when U.S Congress
temporarily canceled the project I
thought NASA was part of the executive
branch sure NASA might be run by the
executive branch but Congress controls
the budget politics are a recurring
theme in this video settle in later in
2011 NASA managed to change congress's
mind on the project by agreeing to limit
the total budget to 8 billion dollars no
more ballooning just for some
perspective that's billion with a b as
in a thousand million yeah the budget
cap was eight of those spoiler alert
they did not keep their Promise by the
time it finally launched in December of
2021 14 years after the original
estimate jwst's total cost was about 10
billion dollars it's not like that was
spent all at once though that's true the
cost was spread over a couple decades
even at Peak spending in the mid-20
teens jwst never accounted for more than
four percent of NASA's annual budget
which itself was always less than one
percent of overall government spending
at the time so while 10 billion dollars
seems like a lot to an average person
like us it's not really that much to a
government especially if it's spread out
but the fact that this project was
spread out also made it cost more as
John Morse would say the cheapest jwst
is the one that launches the soonest
nature wasn't exactly on our side though
we almost lost the telescope to a
hurricane in 2017. then a few years
later the covid-19 pandemic hit and
production stalled we also had to be
absolutely sure this thing was going to
work when we launched Hubble back in
1990 the first pictures were blurrier
than expected luckily we designed Hubble
to be serviceable and launched a repair
mission in 1993. we basically gave it
glasses couldn't we also do that with
jwst unfortunately no this telescope had
to be much farther away it's supposed to
be sensitive to infrared but that's the
kind of light warm things emit if we put
the telescope in orbit around Earth it
would be passing in and out of Earth's
Shadow the temperature of the telescope
itself would change and the sensors
would pick that up it would essentially
make it blind we needed this telescope
to be thermally stable and as cold as
possible so early on the plan was to
launch jwst out to L2 one of Earth's
LaGrange points this would keep it out
of Earth's Shadow and Orient it away
from the Sun at all times all the way
out here jwst would be impossible to
service it had to work perfectly at
launch or we just wasted billions of
dollars and Decades of work so most of
the delays were Justified paranoia but
then the name of the telescope became an
issue NASA had renamed the telescope all
the way back in 2002 it was christened
the James Webb Space Telescope in honor
of James Webb who served as the NASA
administrator from 1961 to 1968. those
were the days of the Space Race the era
of projects Mercury and Gemini we're
talking the first humans in Space the
60s were a big deal for Nassau this
seemed like an easy sell but then an
inflammatory quote surfaced in 2015. I'm
not going to read it aloud because I
can't stomach it it's terribly
homophobic but feel free to pause and
read if you want that's probably not
even a real quote fair just because you
read a quote on the internet that
doesn't make it true but NASA had to
investigate it nonetheless you can't go
naming your new revolutionary telescope
after a homophobe now can you so NASA
was faced with two questions did anyone
actually say it and was it James Webb
NASA thoroughly investigated both
questions and released a 90-page report
with sources Link in the doobly-doo if
you're interested the conclusion of that
investigation is that the quote is real
but James Webb didn't say it
here's what happened this whole thing
blew up when Forbes ran a story on it in
the summer of 2015 but the earliest
story seems to be from earlier that year
in the stranger a local paper in Seattle
who in turn based their story on a quote
from Wikipedia yes that Wikipedia now
just because a quote is on Wikipedia
that doesn't make it wrong but you
should always fact check it come with me
down the rabbit hole Wikipedia
attributed this quote to James Webb and
added it to his biography page in 2011.
the source listed for it was a book
titled towards Stonewall published in
2003 but the author only says that an
under Secretary of State testified at a
senate hearing and that the quote is
from the Senate committee's report not
the under secretary himself though it
does say this unnamed undersecretary had
already fired many state department
employees simply for being homosexual
that hearing took place in February of
1950 and at that time James Webb was the
the under Secretary of State well there
you have it time to get angry no no
Sweet Summer child allow my friend Mr
beat to Enlighten you on the rankings
inside the state department thanks Nick
so the president doesn't have to govern
the United States alone he gets lots of
help and not just from the vice
presidents in fact there's a huge team
working with them it's commonly referred
to as the cabinet today the cabinet
officially includes the heads of 15
executive departments not not
just their heads their whole bodies this
isn't a Futurama episode you know what I
mean like heads like they're in charge
of 15 executive departments
anyway they preside over millions of
employees and hundreds of billions of
dollars one of those executive
departments probably arguably the most
important one is the state department
the person in charge of the state
department is the Secretary of State who
is currently this dude Anthony blinken
now under the secretary of state is the
deputy secretary of state and just to
make this more confusing for you
underneath the deputy secretary of
states are the under secretaries of
state and under the under secretaries of
states are the assistant secretaries of
State
I could go in more detail about all of
this for the next
15 hours or so
how does that sound Nick no no that's
plenty deep enough thanks Matt are you
sure
I've got nothing better to do dude go
outside and touch some grass or
something okay
but I don't have any grass anyway James
Webb held this job it's now called the
deputy secretary but in his day it was
called the undersecretary the titles
changed in 1972. I'm guessing to be less
confusing you can kind of think of him
as the second in command he was to the
Secretary of State what the vice
president is to the president he was
like a backup secretary of state so you
remember that Senate hearing back in
February of 1950 yeah James Webb wasn't
even there the Secretary of State Dean
Atchison was there and so was John
pirifoy the under Secretary of State for
management that position manages the
internal workings of the state
department especially personnel he's the
one that fired all those people in the
Years up to the hearing and it was his
testimony that made this hearing the
start of the lavender scare what's the
lavender scare okay fair I guess this
calls for some context the mid-1900s in
the U.S were kind of a dumpster fire
there was a lot of social and political
turmoil it was a time of extreme
paranoia fear and Prejudice isn't that
the us all the time well it was
particularly bad in the wake of World
War II we had something called the
second Red Scare where everyone was
afraid of the rise of communism
actually I think I'm underselling this
not just afraid that's been pretty
steady since World War One we're talking
full-blown paranoia people were accusing
their friends their neighbors random
people on the street it was Madness and
it was bipartisan in March of 1947 three
years before that Senate hearing
President Truman had signed executive
order 98-35 calling for all government
agencies to investigate their own
employees for possible communist and
subversive Behavior as you can imagine
this order was immediately abused
subversive Behavior unbelievable
starting in the late 40s and through the
60s the line blurred between what was
Communist and what was morally
objectionable there was a mass Purge of
lgbtq plus people from federal positions
it's now known as the lavender scare
were any of them Communists no they they
weren't even all lgbtq plus just
suspected to be but it was argued that
their presence was subversive
the more I learn about American history
I swear anyway this Purifoy guy embraced
Truman's executive order immediately and
fired over 90 people between that order
in 1947 and the Senate Hearing in 1950.
couldn't James Webb or even President
Truman have put a stop to it according
to the records neither James Webb nor
President Truman even knew about the
firings until the Senate hearing by then
it was too late once Congress knew about
it all Truman could do was react he had
a meeting with Webb about the issue and
they did everything they could just to
keep the Personnel investigations
internal to the state department the
alternative was the senate committee
getting the records and investigating
everyone themselves which the president
saw as unacceptable overreach Congress
agreed to the president's terms as long
as they got regular updates and as long
as John Purifoy and his successors had
full authority to fire whoever they
wanted after that Webb's involvement in
the matter ends it was out of his hands
ultimately it didn't even matter that
they tried to cooperate with Congress
two years later James Webb resigned and
went to work in the private sector when
Truman's second term was up in 1953 the
executive branch switched parties the
new president Eisenhower signed
executive order 10 450 which lists
homosexuality explicitly as a national
security risk though they called it
something else at the time in reality
the only thing that made lgbtq plus
people a security risk was the lavender
scare Itself by the time Webb came back
to head NASA in 1961 that Eisenhower
order was still in full effect he worked
hard at Nasa to meet JFK's goals for
Equal Employment and civil rights
unfortunately due to executive order
10450 that could not include sexual
orientation this order would be at full
strength until 1973 well after Webb came
and went at Nassau this was a terrible
time in American history and these sorts
of problems are bigger than one person
that's why after reviewing 50 000 pages
of documents NASA's official report
cleared web of any direct involvement in
the lavender scare in light of that they
chose to keep his name on the telescope
anyway after two decades of budget
increases delays and a huge naming
controversy we finally have the most
epic telescope ever built four different
instruments for detecting infrared light
18 gold hexagonal mirrors because
hexagons are the best-agons all arranged
in a 6.5 meter wide infrared reflector
I'd say it was a miracle that ever got
off the ground but a lot of very skilled
and motivated people made it happen the
people at Nassau are absolutely
incredible we'll have to wait and see
what else jwst has in store for us but I
know what's in store for you over on
nebula me the regular videos I post here
on YouTube will also be on nebula but
completely add and sponsor free there's
also lots of exclusive content from
other creators that you won't see on
YouTube like this DND one shot I was in
a few months ago run by my friend Micah
from neurotransmissions you can watch
the guys from extra credits the roving
naturalist and me play a ragtag team of
characters who have to discover why
everyone in a town is unconscious I
played a dark gnome fighter and it's
honestly one of the best characters I've
ever made and at one point during the
game I failed a surprise check and spent
an entire round bragging to the other
gnome about how I made my hand axes it
was hilarious but like as far as the
temperature goes I mean that's that's
where that's what the forge is for oh
yeah no I totally totally I I know I
know I forged once I feel like I'm
watching an episode of Fortune and fire
if you sign up using my link below
you'll get access to all of it at a huge
discount a whopping 40 off that's only
250 a month for the annual plan 30 bucks
and you get everything on nebula for a
year and because I'm actually part of
the company signing up through my link
directly supports me and my work nebula
is a platform built by creators for
creators and I'm excited to be a part of
it huge thanks to Mr beat for stepping
in and explaining the state department
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy
Bastion 5975 had an Innovative approach
to solving the bowling ball paradox what
you do is make the boat extremely
lightweight that way it's not even
involved after you drop the ball
excellent job avoiding neutronium anyway
thanks for watching